Новини дня «heute» з Мітрі Зіріним.
Доброго вечора всім! Все знову починається спочатку.
Принаймні в німецькій Бундеслізі. Так, Крістін?
Сьогодні ввечері вона стартує.
Так, 15 ігрових днів до Чемпіонату світу.
Огляд сьогоднішніх тем.
Китай проти США:
через тайванську кризу Пекін заморожує співпрацю
у сфері клімату та оборони - Вашингтон реагує.
Вихід із газової кризи:
трубопровід для скрапленого газу з Вільгельмсгафена
будують із  рекордною швидкістю.
А велика пожежа в Берліні частково під контролем,
але зберігається загроза нових вибухів.
Відповідь Китаю на візит до Тайваню
провідної політикині США Пелосі
полягає не лише в початку військових маневрів
навколо Тайваню.
Застосовується також і дипломатична зброя -
Пекін зупиняє співпрацю із США,
принаймні у сфері клімату й оборони.
До того ж було вирішено
накласти санкції на Пелосі та її найближчих родичів.
Із Вашингтону - Ельмар Тевесен.
Це, ймовірно, налякало жителів Тайваню.
Китайські винищувачі знову порушили повітряний простір
навколо острова.
Услід за військовими погрозами тепер політичні -
зупинено співпрацю із США у сфері боротьби
зі зміною клімату,
пандеміями та торгівлею наркотиками.
Це відповідь на критику з боку уряду США
китайських військових навчань.
Заходи Китаю рішучі, потужні
та адекватні.
Військові навчання є прозорими та професійними.
Вони відповідають законам Китаю та
міжнародним законам.
Однак деякі ракети, які Китай випустив
за останні кілька днів,
упали в економічній зоні
сусідньої Японії.
Народно-визвольна армія Китаю стверджує,
що вразила лише цілі навколо Тайваню.
На зустрічі Асоціації держав Південно-Східної Азії
у Камбоджі
атмосфера була напруженою.
На завершення конференції держсекретар США Блінкен
знову висловив критику щодо дій Пекіна.
Візит Пелосі був мирним.
Не було жодних приводів для цієї
агресивної та неадекватної
військової відповіді, яка ще більше загострила конфлікт.
Сьогодні у Токіо Ненсі Пелосі дала зрозуміти,
наскільки важливою для США є співпраця з Китаєм.
Ми повинні співпрацювати з Китаєм
у питанні кліматичної кризи,
тому що ми є двома найбільшими забруднювачами,
і США було б чого повчитися в Китаю.
На думку уряду США, скороченням співпраці із США
Китай шкодить сам собі.
Решта світу може не зрозуміти такого замороження
спільної боротьби із глобальними небезпеками
через небажану поїздку політикині.
Щоб пояснити це, Держдепартамент США
викликав посла Китаю.
З нами Ульф Реллер із Пекіну.
Ульфе, у знак протесту проти візиту Пелосі до Тайваню
Китай зупиняє співпрацю із США.
Тож що задумав Пекін?
Я думаю, що президент Китаю Сі Дзіньпін хоче
передусім показати власну силу перед своїм народом,
адже цей рік є дуже складним для нього.
Справи з економікою зовсім погані.
Основною причиною є стратегія «нульового COVID-19».
Вона паралізує країну.
Серед населення багато невдоволення.
До того ж ще й цей візит,
який змушує президента виглядати слабким.
Варто зазначити, що Сі Дзіньпін чітко дав зрозуміти,
що це буде перетином червоної лінії з боку американців.
Американці ж зробили це відносно свідомо,
так що зараз Сі Дзіньпін виглядає слабким
у власній країні та зазнає сильної внутрішньої критики
з боку націоналістів.
Своїми погрозливими жестами він хоче досягти того,
щоб дипломатичні візити на Тайвань не стали
постійним явищем.
Саме тому він діє так жорстко.
Я не думаю, що він прагне військового конфлікту.
Він не відчуває достатньо сили для цього.
Але все, що за цією лінією, він буде застосовувати,
щоб дати зрозуміти, що він більше не бажає
жодних візитів.
Це своєрідний «армреслінг» між світовими державами
Америкою та Китаєм.
Поки що незрозуміло, чим це закінчиться,
але точно зрозуміло, що міжнародний клімат
стає прохолодним.
Ульф із Пекіна. Дякую за оцінку!
Глава Туреччини Ердоган міг використати
війну в Україні у власних інтересах.
Перебуваючи під внутрішньополітичним тиском,
він ще раніше взяв на себе роль посередника
між Росією та Україною.
Його участь у переговорах щодо зерна була успішною,
у чому він бачить і власний зиск.
Це стосується, зокрема, запровадження заходів
проти курдів на півночі Сирії,
для яких йому потрібна згода Москви.
Сьогодні Ердоган та президент Росії Путін зустрілися
в російському Сочі. Далі - Люк Вальпот.
Показово дружньо прийняв президент Путін
свого турецького колегу Ердогана,
похваливши його за зусилля
у ролі посередника в укладенні «зернової угоди».
Завдяки Вам та ООН
проблему із експортом української пшениці
було вирішено.
За це я хочу подякувати Вам особисто.
Сьогодні вранці ще три судна
із понад 50 тис. тонн кормової кукурудзи на борту
вирушили з українських портів
у напрямку до Босфору.
Під час розмови Путіна й Ердогана йшлося,
крім України,
також і про двосторонню торгівлю та поставки
енергоносіїв із Росії.
Російська компанія «Росатом»
на узбережжі Середземного моря
будує першу турецьку АЕС,
яка нібито має запрацювати наступного року.
Путін наголосив, що поставки російського газу
трубопроводом «Турецький потік»
продовжуються в повному обсязі.
Це цинічна вказівка на те, що оскільки Туреччина,
будучи країною НАТО,
не підтримує західні санкції проти Росії,
справи у неї йдуть краще, ніж у інших.
Європейці мають подякувати Туреччині за те,
що вона уможливлює поставки газу «Турецьким потоком».
Ердоган знову висунув Путіну вимогу
щодо підтримки запланованого ним
військового наступу на курдів на півночі Сирії.
Солідарність є дуже важливою в боротьбі з тероризмом,
тож під час цієї зустрічі
ми сподіваємося досягти прогресу в цьому напрямку.
У Сирії Туреччина підтримує ісламістську опозицію,
а Росія - президента Асада.
Напередодні зустрічі Путін стримано висловився
щодо вимог Ердогана.
Унаслідок авіаатак ізраїльської армії на Сектор Гази
було вбито командира високого рангу
палестинської організації «Ісламський джихад».
За словами ізраїльських військових,
інакше палестинці з Гази атакували б першими.
За даними палестинців,
загинуло щонайменше восьмеро людей
і щонайменше 40 було поранено.
«Ісламський джихад» оголосив,
що буде вжито заходів у відповідь.
В Іраці сотні тисяч людей
приєдналися до масової молитви,
до якої закликав лідер шиїтів аль-Садр.
Вони зібралися в урядовому кварталі Багдада.
Ця п'ятнична молитва є найпершою
демонстрацією влади аль-Садром після того,
як його прибічники вже двічі штурмували парламент.
Він хоче домогтися розпущення парламенту
та проведення дострокових виборів.
На минулих виборах його партія
отримала більшість голосів,
але не змогла сформувати уряд.
Уперше від початку війни в Україні
німецькі газосховища
знову заповнені на понад 70%.
І все ж виникає питання, чи буде цього достатньо,
і як досягти того, щоб газ знову здешевшав.
Запорукою для цього є зріджений природний газ (ЗПГ),
який танкерами доставляють Середземним морем.
У Вільгельмсгафені ще цього року
має з'явитися перший із кількох плавучих терміналів.
Однак бракує близько 26 км трубопроводу
із Вільгельмсгафена до точки подачі газу.
Його мають побудувати за рекордний час.
Далі - Елізабет Шмідт.
Ці 1500 сталевих труб,
кожна з яких важить по дев'ять тонн,
уже в грудні мають бути під землею.
Зазвичай проєкти з будівництва газопроводів тривають
до восьми років, але цей необхідно завершити
за десять місяців.
Це можна зробити лише за умови
значного прискорення процесу надання дозволів.
Наприклад, розробка плану розвитку мережі,
без якого не запускається жоден проєкт у Німеччині,
триває два роки.
Проте Міністерство економіки Німеччини
спільно з Федеральним мережевим агентством,
підготувавши відповідні папери,
вирішили це питання за два тижні.
Зараз триває спорудження будівельної дороги
для будівництва газопроводу завдовжки 26 км.
Була потрібна згода 130 сторін,
власників нерухомості і фермерів.
Деякі з них отримають велику грошову компенсацію.
Якщо все піде за планом, то з 22-го грудня танкери
доставлятимуть зріджений природний газ
до плавучого термінала Вільгельмсгафена.
За допомогою лише цього ЗПГ-термінала
можна було б замінити 20% російського газу щорічно.
Це можна було б зробити й набагато раніше.
Ми занадто довго почувалися розслаблено.
Ми вже планували цей проєкт 2019-го року,
але він провалився через опір у регіоні,
адже тоді всі казали:
«Для чого?! Ми ж маємо російський газ».
Хоча ми вже тоді мали анексію Криму.
Хоча ми мали б бути набагато
мудрішими щодо запитання:
«А чи не занадто ми залежні?».
Опір є і зараз - з боку екологічних організацій.
Проте він став тихішим.
Вони скаржаться передусім на те,
що через поспішне ухвалення закону
про прискорення розширення мережі ЗПГ-терміналів
у них майже не було часу для заперечень.
Через забивання паль, здійснюване з великою силою,
виникає рівень шуму,
який шкодить морському середовищу.
Особливо це стосується морських свиней,
популяція яких суворо охороняється.
Але в часи газової війни з Росією
безпека постачання стоїть на першому місці.
У Вільгельмсгафені все свідчить
про будівництво в турборежимі.
Зріджений газ доставляється, звичайно, не Середземним,
а Північним морем. Перепрошую.
Авіамандрівники можуть трохи видихнути з полегшенням.
«Lufthansa» досягла угоди
про значне підвищення заробітної плати
у тарифному конфлікті із наземним персоналом.
Завдяки угоді з Об'єднаною профспілкою
працівників сфери обслуговування
подальшим страйкам можна буде запобігти,
принаймні серед наземного персоналу.
У декілька етапів заробітна плата
приблизно 20 тис. працівників
буде збільшена на мінімум 325 євро на місяць.
Додатково очікується
загальне підвищення зарплати на 2,5%,
а мінімальна заробітна плата зросте
до 13 євро за годину.
У тарифному конфлікті з пілотами
згоди досі не дійшли.
Місяцями пандемія коронавірусу
обмежувала мільйони школярів.
Мало очних занять,
більш або менш успішні онлайн-уроки.
Результат - прогалини в знаннях
у багатьох дітей і підлітків.
Також цього літа спеціальні навчальні табори
покликані допомогти зменшити дефіцит знань.
З Саксонії-Ангальт повідомляє Хаген Мікулас.
За п'ять днів вони надолужать те,
що пропустили під час онлайн-занять.
Для цього учні п'ятих і шостих класів
долучилися до навчального табору в
Наумбурзі в Саксонії-Ангальт.
Багато дітей бояться, що не надолужать
пропущений матеріал.
Оскільки я долучалася до занять,
у мене з'явилися прогалини у знаннях.
Вони ставали все більшими.
В результаті, я втратила мотивацію вчитися,
оскільки я думала, що нічого не досягну.
Мої оцінки з англійської були невисокими.
Моя мама вважає,
що для мене краще бути тут
і трохи підучитися під час канікул,
щоб у сьомому класі я зміг
надолужити шкільну програму
і не залишитися ще на один рік.
Саксонія-Ангальт запровадила
26 навчальних таборів із конкретних предметів.
Чотири години на день математики,
німецької, біології або англійської
повинні принаймні зменшити дефіцит знань,
а також спілкування завдяки спільному дозвіллю
у другій половині дня.
Звичайно, одного тижня для цього недостатньо.
Але це буде невеликим внеском
у мотивацію учнів до навчання.
Нещодавнє загальнонаціональне дослідження,
проведене Берлінським університетом ім. Гумбольдта,
показало, що учні четвертих класів
відстають у навчанні на шість місяців.
Такі додаткові пропозиції є хорошим кроком.
Проте експерти в галузі освіти стверджують,
що для стійкого скорочення дефіциту знань
потрібно більше зусиль.
Якщо навчальні табори організовані правильно,
вони забезпечують «швидкий старт»,
тобто учні починають навчальний рік
особливо мотивованими,
особливо цілеспрямованими і добре підготованими.
Але надалі це має тривати в такому ж дусі.
Це означає, що нам потрібні концепції
для індивідуальної підтримки,
які були б ефективними протягом навчального року.
Табір у Наумбурзі поєднує навчання та спілкування.
Для 17 дітей, що знаходяться тут,
це крок до давно втраченої нормальності.
Речі, які сприймаються як належне,
ставляться під сумнів
у приголомшливому темпі.
Сюди належить і постійний доступ до води -
одного з найважливіших ресурсів.
І не тільки у нашій країні.
Як зазначено на мапі помаранчевим кольором,
у 45% регіонів ЄС було
попередження про посуху в липні.
Також у значній частині Нідерландів.
Флоріан Нойганн розповідає про те,
як наші сусіди справляються з посухою.
У Неймегені в Нідерландах
мешканці цих будинків на воді
відчувають посуху цілком конкретно,
тому що частково їхні будинки
опинилися на суходолі.
Дехто навіть переїхав,
оскільки їхні човни сильно нахилилися.
Вони більше не могли нормально ходити.
Вже кілька тижнів не випадає достатньо опадів.
Деякі канали вже закриті для судноплавства,
і уряд офіційно оголосив надзвичайний стан через воду.
На практиці це означає, що зараз ми
на національному рівні вирішуємо,
як розподіляти воду.
Наприклад, фермерам в багатьох регіонах
необхідно скоротити обсяги зрошення.
Постачання питної води наразі не порушено.
Проте всі закликають заощаджувати воду,
тим більше, що поліпшення ситуації не передбачається.
Така посуха, зазвичай, не характерна для серпня.
І це вже не перший рік.
Ми вже зазнавали такої посухи
у 2018, 2019 та 2020 роках.
Вона вже не минула безслідно.
Дефіцит води - явище, яке стосується
значної частини Європи.
Ось чому все більшого значення набуває
очищення та повторне використання стічних вод.
Такої ж думки дотримується комісія ЄС.
Вона опублікувала нові рекомендації з цього питання.
Дуже важливо, щоб ми відповідально
використовували воду.
І крім того, дотримувалися санітарних норм.
Про важливість води в Нідерландах
також свідчать їхні дамби,
які захищають ту частину країни,
що лежить нижче рівня моря.
Посуха загрожує зробити дамби нестійкими.
Тому їх обслуговування - питання безпеки.
Незначне полегшення в берлінському Грюневальді.
Частину пожежі там уже загасили.
Проте ризик детонацій навколо місця вибуху
залишається високим.
Дві бомби часів Світової війни
заважають роботі аварійних служб.
Досі незрозуміло, чому виникла пожежа.
Маркус Гросс з репортажем.
Незначний дощик сьогодні вранці
не приніс реальної допомоги
для Берлінської пожежної служби.
Кілометри шлангів,
багато осередків пожежі вже загашено.
Пожежники працювали понад 36 годин.
Вранці вони змогли підійти ближче
до місця вибуху.
Також завдяки роботам з дистанційним керуванням
та бронемашинам,
що використовуються для гасіння та розвідки.
Наразі ситуація спокійніша,
ніж учора.
Тим більше, якщо погода буде такою, як зараз,
не варто очікувати погіршення ситуації.
Як показують останні аерофотознімки,
все ще залишаються невеликі ділянки займання.
Але їх не порівняти з учорашніми фотографіями.
Декілька сильних детонацій, великі пожежі,
що нагріли землю до 700°.
Роботи з гасіння пожежі там неможливі,
оскільки авіабомби, що зберігаються там,
зірвані з анкерних кріплень.
Зараз вони охолоджуються роботами-пожежниками,
але лежать на майданчику без охорони.
Йдеться про два боєприпаси, які були скинуті там
за часів Другої світової війни.
Ціль - досягти низької температури,
щоб до ділянки можна було підійти.
Тільки після усунення цих небезпек
можна зменшити оточену зону.
Прилегла траса та залізнична лінія поки закриті.
Досі невідомо, коли буде відновлено рух.
Отже, час підготовки закінчився,
початок гри трохи більше ніж за годину, Крістін?
Головним матчем суботнього вечора стане поєдинок
між минулорічним суперником «Баварії»,
який посів друге місце, -
клубом «Боруссія Дортмунд» та «Байєр Леверкузен»,
що був третім в турнірі.
Натхненний домашньою перевагою, розпродані квитки -
«BVB» хоче подати приклад.
Вперше на посаді головного тренера
перед таким натовпом.
Едін Терзіч з Дортмунда
із попутним вітром після виїзної перемоги
у Кубку на стадіоні 1860 Мюнхена.
Це був дуже гарний початок сезону.
Ми захищалися професійно.
І рішуче.
Ось чому вони запросили таку людину,
як Ніко Шлоттербек з Фрайбурга.
Однак його партнер у центральному захисті Ніклас Зюле
відсутній через травму і його замінить Гуммельс.
Під час шторму відповідальність буде розподілено.
Голланд, наступник Аллера,
буде відсутній довше через хворобу.
Настрій у «Леверкузені» після кубкової поразки
був зовсім іншим.
Це був перший матч змагання,
в якому щось було поставлено на кону,
і ми все зіпсували.
Поразка 3:4 від команди третього дивізіону «Елверсберга»
зіпсувала настрій гравцям на декілька днів, але:
Я відчуваю бажання та волю команди
негайно покращити результат.
Остання гра в Дортмунді: засіб для підвищення настрою.
«Леверкузен» переміг у лютому з рахунком 5:2.
Все про топову гру і початок Бундесліги -
завтра ввечері у «Aktuelles Sportstudio».
Бігунка з перешкодами Геза-Феліцітас Краузе
відмінила участь у Чемпіонаті Європи
в Мюнхені через хворобу.
Наступного четверга стартують дев'ять видів спорту.
Там будуть присутні багато зірок,
включно з головною зіркою німецької легкої атлетики.
Її місія у здобутті золота триває:
Чемпіонка світу Малайка Міхамбо
захищатиме свій титул чемпіонки Європи у Мюнхені.
Вона найбільша німецька медальна надія
у легкій атлетиці.
Жіноча команда з естафетного бігу 4 х 100 метрів
під керівництвом Джини Люкенкемпер,
яка виборола бронзу на Чемпіонаті світу, також хоче
увійти до трійки лідерів на чемпіонаті Європи.
У гімнастиці на медаль претендує Лукас Даузер,
срібний призер Токіо на брусах
та чемпіон Німеччини у багатоборстві.
Яннік Флохе, чинний чемпіон світу
зі скелелазання у двоборстві
та володар Кубка світу у болдерінгу,
також націлений на перемогу.
Загалом у Мюнхені буде вручено 177 медалей.
І ми вестимемо пряму трансляцію.
Чи можна ще буде купатися,
розкаже Кріста Орбен в прогнозі погоди..
Пізніше Крістіан Зіверс прокоментує цей день новин
у випуску «heute journal» о 22:00.
Дякуємо за перегляд
від усієї команди «heute 19 Uhr»
і бажаємо гарних вихідних.
Доброго вечора!
Cупутниковий знімок, зроблений сьогодні вдень,
показує нам хмари холодного фронту,
який проходить по всій країні.
Завдяки йому сьогодні в Куксхафені
температура опустилася до 19°.
Однак до холодного фронту в Регенсбурзі
знову було дуже жарко - 36°.
У цій спекотній південно-східній половині країни
з другої половини дня
пройшли сильні грози -
і так продовжуватиметься ввечері та вночі.
Від Берліна та Бранденбурга до Альп
пройдуть зливи та грози.
Найбільший ризик шторму існує у Подунав’ї
та на південь від нього.
Там очікується град і сильні пориви вітру,
також пройдуть сильні дощі,
що подекуди триватимуть годинами,
тому остерігайтеся повеней.
Різниця температур зберігається і вночі:
при ясному небі охолоджується до 8°,
при грозовому повітрі - до 18°.
Завтра різниця вже буде не такою помітною:
19° на узбережжі і більш приємні 27° на Рейні.
Погода теж заспокоїться:
на південь від Дунаю буде дуже хмарно,
місцями зливи або грози,
на інших територіях сонячно та малохмарно.
Наступні кілька днів минуть під впливом високого тиску -
сонячно, малохмарно і майже без дощу.
Температура буде приємною - від 20-32°. До побачення!